the title of my piece is government
almost killed the cocktail the old
fashioned is an extremely simple drink
to make but in many ways it represents
the ideal of what a good cocktail should
be it's an ideal and an idea that we
almost lost thanks to Prohibition what
happened wasn't just that we lost the
booze or the recipes we also lost a lot
of the knowledge from those celebrity
bartenders in many cases the bartender's
retired in some cases they went over to
Europe and when Prohibition ended they
weren't around to teach people how to
drink well again so in the decades after
prohibition what we had was a kind of
cocktail Dark Ages where people didn't
really know how to make a good cocktail
a lot of liqueurs just weren't available
during that time in part because
prohibition had really drawn down the
stock of aged spirits thankfully in the
1990s a couple of bartenders started
looking at pre-prohibition cocktail
books in some cases they even went so
far as to resurrect old spirits that
hadn't been made for decades so while
government almost killed the cocktail
thankfully American bartenders brought
it back from the brink of death and
today may be the best time of all to
have a drink in America Cheers
[Music]
you